[Music]
the reason you can't say that only
University can come into being out of
nothing is because nothing doesn't have
any properties and so therefore can't
have a kind of preference for universes
over other things yeah my my response to
that was to say what if the what if the
the necessity of it being a universe is
not a property if they're nothing but a
property of the thing and and let me
explain myself if for example if we
human beings create a circle it has to
be round right we can't create a square
circle all right but that's not due to a
property of us that's due to a property
of the circle right yeah so in the same
way although nothing has no properties
and so can't prefer universes what if it
can only what if only universes can come
from nothing because of a property of
the universe not because of the property
of nothing right
his response isn't that like the
opposite of what happened during the
debate during the debate he said that
you're putting words in my mouth well
let's watch what he says in the debate
yeah let's see what he says in the
review yeah I'm beginning to get the
impression that Muhammad hijab wants me
to justify my claim that the universe
began to exist out of nothing okay
slight problem with that I never said
that Muhammad hijab has quoted me
quoting someone else's belief quoting me
quoting a belief that I don't agree with
and it's claiming that I was making that
claim so that's quite interesting
because he's obviously making a point
that you're attacking a straw man in the
debate he didn't say that and then he
told you something and he said no no no
I didn't say that okay here he's
actually making it very clear that that
is a potential answer out of whatever
volume William Lane Craig was making
what do you make of that I don't know I
genuinely don't know what this guy is
about because I I thought what the hell
is this is it why would he even put that
after having made this massive video
seriously this massive video saying oh
he misrepresented me misquoted me I
don't believe that laughing it's mine
why would you then go and say the same
thing the same thing to William Lane
Craig
of all people in the world yeah who's
seen as one of the Masters of the
Colombo's much call him in West he knows
what you're saying he understood it the
way I understood it hmm and then he
proceeds to this destroying yeah unless
his response actually he had a very
interesting response right yeah so in
the same way although nothing has no
properties and so can't prefer universe
is what if it can only what if only
universes can come from nothing because
of a property of the universe not
because of the property of nothing right
that's that is exactly what you would
have to say because as you say
properties only in here in existing
things beings have properties not non
being so you'd actually it's an inherent
property of the universe that it can
spring into existence properly the
reason why I think it's useful to think
in in those terms or at least of the
possibility of it happening is because
specifically the objection that why
don't things pop into existence all the
time I suppose what I'm trying to do is
make a at least a far-fetched case I'm
trying to show at least a possibility
published yeah things could come into
existence out of nothing and yet by
definition and we'd be incapable of
witnessing it so maybe things do come
into existence out of nothing all the
time because this guy's taking this
guy's joking he's saying things come out
of existence no no but he is saying is
far-fetched yeah he's saying why are you
saying that is far-fetched because it's
a potential it's a potentially why is it
a potential that something's constant
distance of nothing all the time you
just like the whole video saying that
was misrepresentation yeah yeah yeah but
watch this watch this
I love Craigslist once
let me commend you for your method as
missing because by pushing these
questions what you help the atheist to
see is the intellectual price tag
yes of his atheism this is too funny
about this stupid Christian apologist
that's that's the roasting that's always
like he's four years getting prison is
like
yes raised the intellectual price tag of
non-belief and if the basement oh my god
requires me to be a need merry illogical
knee list to think that things have an
intrinsic property that they can come
into being that other things don't have
this is all raising the intellectual
price tag of non-belief i love that for
me at least Alex just way way beyond
what I'm willing to pay
you